ALBERT EINSTEIN (VOICEOVER):
Based on this new phenomenon,
it is conceivable,
though much less certain,
that an extremely powerful
bomb of a new type
may be constructed.
FRANKLIN DELANO ROOSEVELT:
A single bomb of this type,
carried by boat and
exploded in a port,
might very well destroy the
whole port together with some
of the surrounding territory.
Good god.
I don't need to
tell you what could
happen if the Germans developed
this technology before we do.
I'll be doing the goose step.
--[chuckles] Or worse,
which is why I'm asking you
to take charge of a
program to research
and develop an atomic weapon.
It would require
tremendous resources.
Of that, I have no doubt.
I need wide latitude
to manage the project--
the scientists, the military,
clandestine operations.
Secrecy would be vital, sir.
You couldn't let the
crowds get onto us.
Everyone involved will
need security clearance.
EDGAR: Oppenheimer,
Teller, Fermi, Einstein.
Hm.
No.
[closes notebook]
No, Einstein is out.
MILITARY OFFICIAL: You haven't
even run his background, Edgar.
EDGAR: The Bureau
has been concerned
about Einstein for years.
He's a radical, most
certainly communist.
MILITARY OFFICIAL: He's the
man who informed the president
of the urgency of this matter.
He cannot be trusted to
be loyal to our country.
I will support and defend
the Constitution and laws of
the United States of America.
Against all enemies,
foreign and domestic.
JUDGE: That I will bear arms
on behalf of the United States
when required by the law.
That I will bear arms on
behalf of the United States
when required by the law.